Detroit is that historic hub for
automakers but that industry is getting
21st century competition from Silicon
Valley the Ford Motor Company is
stepping up efforts to compete it will
reveal plans this morning to transform a
hundred and five year old train station
into its high-tech base for the future
of automotive mobility Gale got a look
at that space that you'll see only on
CBS this morning she's in McAllen Texas
Gail good morning good morning to you
Nora but last week I was in Detroit see
the places you get to go on CBS this
morning
yep we get to travel on this job I like
it but as you were saying this is an
amazing old building and in a very
exciting project for both Ford and the
city of Detroit Ford executive chairman
Bill Ford jr. wants this real estate
project to give Silicon Valley a run for
its money he recently gave us a tour of
the very historic space Detroit was
built in an era where there was a ton of
money here and so buildings like this
were built with grandeur and then they
fell into disrepair over its 105 year
history the massive Michigan central
train station in Detroit has reflected
the life in times of the city around it
this had to be the ticket booth right
when the railroad was king the station
stood as a symbol of Detroit's
prosperity then the city's economy
collapsed and fell into bankruptcy had
we been looking at this ten years ago he
would had a lot of empty buildings there
you know whenever they show a picture of
how bad Detroit is this is the place the
poster child that used to always drive
me somebody has lived here my whole life
I hated that kind of publicity for our
city and for this structure what are you
thinking now a Ford Motor Company
executive chairman Bill Ford jr. is
doing something about that his company
just bought this half a million square
foot behemoth and is turning it into
Ford's new hub for autonomous and
electric vehicle research when we
started thinking about the future of
transportation and autonomous driving
it's very clear that that will happen
first in cities and therefore we have to
get experience on city streets and
cityscapes is where that will all be
invented the 2,500 Ford employees who
are expected to work here
will do
more than transform a building they will
also help revive an entire neighborhood
Corktown one of the oldest parts of the
city your love for Detroit is very clear
to me I mean it's important for you to
be here in the city it is and Legacy
Project for you yeah this is really you
know for me a great kind of homecoming
if you will his ancestors including
great-grandfather Henry Ford the
legendary founder of the company were
settled here in the late 19th century I
think everybody when Detroit hit
rock-bottom said ok what's all just
pulled together and make this place for
us
and there's a spirit now in the city to
do just that and a good example of that
spirit happened just over the weekend an
unnamed thief who stole an antique clock
that used to hang in the station
returned it on Friday he apparently
tipped off fort officials who retrieved
it from an abandoned lot two miles from
the station they have authenticated it
using old photos and chemical analysis
no word on how long it was gone or what
Ford plans to do with it in the
renovation but something tells me it's
going to show up there Alex to steal
your pun Bill Ford jr. is driving the
company forward I like that I liked it I
liked to see that everything for Detroit
so we're going to show you more of this
project tomorrow bill 4 talks to Gail
about autonomous driving what his
ancestors would think of Ford's future
and his Western car making rival Elon
Musk so more straight ahead and that's
tomorrow on CBS this morning